i don't really know i'm going to leave
the interview now i kind of only came on
here because i thought it would be kind
of funny but i want to say you're and
saving women all of them with the queen
of mean and robinson she's here live
good evening anne
i can't hear anything
[Laughter]
you know what save it for the interview
like i should i should just
take tyson fury and tweet
last dance question mark
well being liberal used to mean
believing in free speech tolerance and
respect for those with different
opinions but today's woke version of
liberals seems hell-bent on behaving
like the fascists they claim to hate
don't take my word for it the world's
richest man elon musk one of the most
famous free speech advocates in the
world right now says he cannot no longer
vote for the democrats he's voted for
his entire life
and i i would class myself as as a
moderate and you know neither republican
nor nor democrat um and in fact i have
voted vote overwhelmingly for democrats
uh historically overwhelmingly like i'm
not sure
i might never have voted for a
republican just to be clear right now
now this election i would
well muscled took to twitter the
platform he's trying to buy of course to
help restore free speech and he said the
democrats have become his words the
party of division and hate and that he
now expects biblical attacks on him to
escalate well he was completely right he
was bombarded with abuse from the moment
he tweeted what he said about the
democrats and this afternoon he said
judging by the relentless hate stream
from the far left this tweet was spot on
it was and so is elon musk the very
people who claim to be the good guys
often with their ironic be kind hashtags
on their profiles are the same people
leading this vicious opinion purge
they just can't accept that people with
different views have any right to say
them they use abuse mob rule and
bullying to silence the shame opponents
or even hound them out of their jobs
this is not liberalism it's
authoritarianism defending free speech
has been sacrificed at the woke altar of
defending an increasingly ridiculous and
often imaginary group of gender
minorities as well as fellow wokies of
course try asking a regular voter on the
doorstep in britain in america in
australia what their pronouns are
they wonder what the hell you're talking
about
mine for the record are me myself and i
sadly liberals have shifted their hearts
from factories to faculties issues based
is now plant-based partisan is now
artisan it's supposed to be all politics
is local not locally sourced
the democratic party should be the
natural home of a genius innovator who
believes passionately in his country in
ideas and in free speech the fact is not
is another symptom of what musk calls
the woke virus please
somebody for the love of god develop a
vaccine against this before we all get
infected i is that possible i don't see
why not well i i do think martin luther
lovers said you know that the number 300
male tennis player if he wanted to
transition either legitimately or to
cheat
could do so without having any surgery
and would just reduce their testosterone
level but not their physical body mass
and become the greatest tennis player in
history on the women's side and then
three years later go back to are you
interviewing me or am i interviewing you
because you're doing all the talking
okay can i just no let me say something
say something right honestly
i've only got 15 minutes
the amount of um trans who actually have
surgery is minuscule yeah
so actually i don't know about this um
trans in this particular case but it's
so easy
i could suddenly decide to be a male
athlete when you see politicians who
can't answer what is a woman yeah a what
do you feel about that what is the
answer the answer is a woman is someone
with a vagina do you need to say that
again it is somebody with a vagina
and i can now be cancelled professional
footballers are among the most lavishly
paid athletes in the world top players
can earn millions every month but
kicking a ball around which obviously
sounds ridiculous in an economic crisis
but their salaries are driven by market
force they get paid a lot of money
because they're the best of what they do
and they make a lot of money for their
teams and the same simple economic
calculation should apply to men and
women
that's why i'm in total agreement today
with the groundbreaking decision by the
us soccer federation not with their
decision to call themselves soccer
federation it's football but their
decision to pay its women team the same
amount it pays the men u.s women have
fought hard for equal pay for years and
here's their victorious captain today
i am feeling extreme pride and to be
able to say finally equal pay for equal
work feels very very good
well she should she's earned it they all
have the us women's football team is a
ruthless winning machine skilled strong
resilient champions they've won four
world cups four olympic goals compare
that with the us men's team which has
won absolutely nothing it's about as
entertaining to watch as a meghan markle
podcast it's not realistic right now for
all female sports teams or individual
sports women to earn the same as male
counterparts it depends on the sport the
level of success their star power and
particularly on revenue streams from
crowds and television but in this case
it's a no-brainer the us women's team
may be very smug
and annoying
but honestly they've got every right to
be
they're more successful than the us
men's team by far they get bigger crowds
just as many sponsors and actually much
bigger stars
if anything they should be paid more
than the men this is the other question
you know people forget that hollywood is
a business uh so for example when
scarlett johansson uh
was uh stopped from playing uh a trans
role yeah uh
there wasn't there simply wasn't a
trance actress at that point big enough
to sustain a 50-60 million dollar movie
i found that was a mistake of the trans
community because there were probably
lots of other trance roles in the film
that would have been played by uh trans
actresses and uh
scarlett johansson wasn't going to be
doing some portrait that was anti-trans
so i felt it was slightly
blinkered attitude they are legitimate
areas of concern you can't just call
you can go and have a look at their
websites you can have a look at their
twitters
like they are transphobic but i am
kicked out
okay look look i'm trying to give you a
chance i've explained my position
what is your problem with my position
i don't really know i'm going to leave
the interview now i kind of only came on
here because i thought it would be kind
of funny but i want to say you're and
you're
all right well i apologize again to all
uh viewers who are listening to that
unfortunately a complete idiot are you
prepared if it comes to it to
lose your life to fight for your country
i asked mike
myself this question when russian forces
were in outskirts of the city
and if i wouldn't be ready for it i
would have left
the city of kiev with almost 5 million
people like a sponge
it's big city and busy city was empty
you could hear the explosions
constant
explosion because the fights were going
on in the outskirts of the city
and
you must count with anything while
you're in cave or in ukraine with
anything
even now and this question is basically
everyone in ukraine ukrainian or not and
as you know they're journalists your
colleagues journalists been killed
precisely with sniper shots
and lost their lives if you're in
ukraine you must
you must know that that could be your
last moment in life
last trip in life and
are you ready to give up anything you
have for the country and freedom and
that's the question that
millions of ukraine is asking and the
answer is yes because you could do
anything for your children anything for
your country anything for your parents
anything that
that you love
and
that's something that just
cannot be in a different in a different
way
you